it was the last of its kind to bear a
name that stood for german automotive
tradition
fifty years ago an era came to an end
with the dkw f-12 roadster
launched in 1964 it was the last auto
union model
its maker in ingelstadt later evolved
into luxury car maker audi
it's a classic cabriolet that's
enjoyable for its charming
idiosyncrasies its top is easily
retracted and with the passenger
compartment open to the elements the f12
offers a very special kind of driving
pleasure
but perhaps the most distinctive feature
of the little roadster is the typical
high-pitched putt-putt putt of its smoky
two-stroke engine
auto union proudly unveiled the f-12 in
1964.
the company hoped it would revive its
fortunes
sales had collapsed at the end of the
1950s buyers were mostly gravitating to
the vw beetle
the f11 and f12 series wore auto union's
answer to the vw two sedans in the lower
mid-range segment that offered
front-wheel drive but the modern design
was let down by the obsolete two-stroke
engine
however despite the noise and the smoke
the three-cylinder power plant delivers
an impressive 33 kilowatts around seven
more than the old vw beetle
the four rings represent the four car
makers that merged to form auto union
one of them was dkw
after the war dkw engineers built on the
brand's successful history
besides motorcycles and scooters the
company produced small and mid-sized
cars powered by two-stroke engines
dkw expert alfresa says the car suffered
from auto union's marketing strategy for
the brand it was supposed to compete
against the vw beetle the very symbol of
germany's post-war boom dkw could only
dream of the beatles sales figures it
couldn't come close
even though the roadster didn't sell in
huge numbers it was meant to boost the
dowdy image of dkw's range
the f-12 and especially the rank-top
version offered a sober but welcome
interior with clear instruments and
enough space for four people
things this tv commercial from 1964
was very keen to emphasize
the ad said it's not just a car it's a
way of looking at life it's optimism
with 45 horsepower
the fully retractable roof creates a
completely new driving experience
you're at one with nature and enjoy a
panorama of 360 degrees
your vacation will be more beautiful
even sunnier
a true picture of a car
no
when they built the convertible the auto
union engineers sought expert help from
stuttgart bodywork specialists carousely
bauer
the f-12 roadster was relatively
powerful by mid-1960 standards despite
its tiny 0.9 liter displacement the
engine has enough pulling power but only
at high revs
and compared to today's high-tech
engines the two-stroke was simplicity
itself it was easy to maintain and
repair
but it was dkw's fatal weakness while
the two-stroke was successful in
motorsport in everyday traffic it was
increasingly seen as an unrefined
stinker which produced unbearable
exhaust
a separate tank supplied the two-stroke
engine with its vital lubricating oil
dkw stayed with the simple and
lightweight two-stroke engine till the
very end even after all other
manufacturers had abandoned it for
four-stroke engines
in 1965 auto union was taken over by its
rival volkswagen the new owners killed
off the dkw brand and with it the
production of two-stroke car engines in
west germany
but even today two strokes have their
diehard fans
today an f-12 road stirring top
condition is a rarity collectors will
pay 17 000 euros or more for a good
specimen
but the four rings lived on volkswagen
revived one of auto union's other old
brands and the success story of audi
began
its first models were based on dkw
designs powered by a mercedes
four-stroke four-cylinder engine
you